focus on the things that you can change
in your business not the things that are
outside of your control hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today
makes it a question from one of my
newsletter readers George who wrote an
essay why do most entrepreneurs come
from poor or middle income families
thank you so George you know what it's
true if you look at the most successful
entrepreneurs in the world we've
profiled a lot of them on my website
most of them started from nothing didn't
start coming from a rich family didn't
have huge investors in their business
they came from nothing and when you are
forced to do everything yourself when
you learn the skills of survival that
helps you build a successful company
when you don't have a huge safety net
behind you when you have tons of
investors it helps teach you the skills
to run a successful business you have to
cut your teeth and you have to grind it
out to get to that point of survival and
Beyond and if you start off with nothing
you are forced to learn those skills so
it's true that most of these successful
famous entrepreneurs that you look at
came from very poor or moderate families
but my question is so what like who
cares this will not have an impact on
your business whatever family you are
born into that's the family if you grew
up in a middle-class family or a poor
family or rich family you can't change
that and you don't want any of those
things to be an excuse for you not to go
and give it your best no matter what
odds you have stacked against you or for
you you still have to go out and do the
work if you can't change your situation
you can't change things like that then
don't worry about it focus on the things
that will help you grow instead of
thinking about will I have success or
not because of what family I come from
which has no impact think about things
like how I'm going to get my next
customer how am I going to bring money
into my business how am I going to grow
how am I going to bring on a team that's
all helpful super valuable really
important stuff that you need to focus
on
make sure you're asking yourself the
right questions and don't use any of
those things as an excuse for not giving
it your best you don't want to say oh I
didn't come from a rich family so I'm
not going to have success as an
entrepreneur you make your own odds
don't worry about the things that are
outside your control focus on the things
that you can change focus on those
things and your business will grow good
luck George for those of you watching if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below and I want to hear from
you please leave a comment below I love
seeing those come in every day and I
want to hear what's going on with your
business if there's a question I can ask
leave it in the comments section thanks
guys I'll see you in the next episode